we conducted the world's largest study
of high performers and i learned one new
concept i didn't know how important it
was and this concept is called raising
your psychological necessity big fancy
phrase let me tell you what it means and
why it's so important for you to be
basically awesome in everything that you
do okay i'll give you a story about it
to explain the concept i was working
with this gold medalist olympic sprinter
so this person is just absolutely elite
at what they do and we were out on the
track and the person was kind of getting
ready for their warm-up and everything
and we're just talking about competition
like you know the competitors and uh
sprinters in a sport where you know the
difference between first and second
place might be a tenth of a second or a
hundredth of a second it's really close
so i said you know when you're thinking
about your competition how do you even
know who's going to win i mean when you
go down to the blocks and you put your
hands down you're putting the block
you're getting ready to go you're
waiting for that gun to go off and
you're looking across the other people
or thinking about the other people how
do you know who's gonna win that race
and he says i'm gonna bet on the person
who looks at the finish line and says
i'm gonna do this for my mom
and i was like wow
and that kind of explains the concept of
performance necessity performance
necessity is using your mind and priming
your mind in a way that makes you doing
a good job in that specific activity
a must and not a preference
there's a lot of things that people
would like to do or want to do but they
don't do it because the psychological
necessity is not there meaning it's not
necessary for them to perform well it's
not necessary for them to excel or to
win there so they don't but what i found
in this huge study was that high
performers like to a t
they all kind of psych themselves up
going into the major activities if
they're walking into work that day
they're gonna go i'm gonna crush it
today and then they say things to
themselves with their self-talk that
make them crush it that day wanna be
happy build a life not just a business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back a lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside you too
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and learn the seven
rich people habits that you need to try
enjoy
habit number two reflect with robin
sharma the ritual of private reflection
well it's very easy to be busy being
busy
but let me ask you what's the point of
being really busy in your work life or
your personal life if you're busy around
the wrong things i mean it makes no
sense to spend the best hours of your
finest days climbing these mountains
only to realize on the last hour of your
last day
you climbed the wrong ones
and so what is the antidote to busyness
and being reactive it's reflection
and it's not really common in our world
right now you know
a hundred years ago we would spend a lot
of time on the farm i mean there wasn't
a lot of technology we spent a lot of
time in reflection you know taking these
long walks
writing in a journal having
conversations with intimate friends
where would we where would we would
reflect on deeper things and i'm simply
suggesting to you that the fifth ritual
that will absolutely predict your
success is how much time you spend in
silence
solitude and stillness
just thinking
thinking about how you're living
thinking about how you're working
thinking about whether your daily
behavior is aligned with your deepest
values
thinking and reflecting about
what you want your legacy to be
thinking and reflecting about what's
your impact through the work you're
doing here's the thing a great thing to
reflect on ask yourself this question or
write about it in your journal
what is the one project that if i did it
flawlessly over the next three months
would literally change the game for me
within my organization and within my
marketplace but if you look at the
people who are getting traction on great
results they are people who spend a lot
of time alone
and they spend a lot of time thinking
and they spend a lot of time in this
ritual of reflection habit number three
understand the power of language with
tony robbins early in my life i
developed this belief that life is
calling not to give me something life is
calling for me to deliver things for me
to bring something to life and i felt
the the joy that came from not getting
but giving and i got hooked on that core
pattern and then the pattern of learning
so i'd have something to give which i
know one things i respect about you
louis is that you have that same pattern
in you you're you're always trying to
learn more because underneath it all you
also want to give it you want it you
want it for you but you want to share it
right and so those patterns help me not
be what they're not giving and all this
language language
today people don't understand the power
of their language like toxic
what the hell are you talking about
you've been want reading too much social
media and thinking about yourself or
somebody raised you to constantly judge
your videos we live in a culture now
where people you know you're evil or
you're like me
that's basically how it is right the
whole world everybody else does it more
unless they do what you do think what
you think experience you think i mean
being a liberal i was a liberal right
being a liberal growing up meant you i
would i would fight for your ability to
say and believe whatever you want
different than me today now everybody
wants everybody to think the same thing
otherwise they're evil or otherwise they
could hurt me whatever happens sticks
and stones will break your bones and
words will never hurt me we have this
whole thing that words are evil words
are action word it's bullsh
and all it does is make you incredibly
weak as a human being and you're more
than that
we all are more than that but you know
what like a kid that's never broken
their bones definitely afraid of
breaking the bone but if you're a kid
and you're rough and dumb you broke
multiple bones they heal you don't have
any fear of it
there's so many kids that have been
raised to be safe and secure every
moment anything that's insecure or
unsafe they don't want to be a part of
including language
and what it does is make you incredibly
weak and fearful and that's why there's
so many people that are abundant that
are angry all the time
because they're angry because they're
not growing
so
don't get me wrong
i know some people are not a good
influence i'm not denying that i'm just
saying you're more than somebody's
influence unless you obsess about it
every moment and make them wrong so you
can make yourself feel superior morally
psychologically or spiritually that's
[ __ ] stop the pattern we've all done
it catch yourself also to make sure
you're actually taking action after
watching this video i've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the lessons learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there habit number four persevere with
les brown what's the scripture that when
i first heard it and
read it i just said oh boy that's
that's cold-blooded i just couldn't
i couldn't wrap my
mind around it didn't have any
compassion
in it
he that hath
shall get
and he that hath not
even that that he has
shall be
taken away
oh my god you sing it he that hath
the person that we have
they will get and the person who don't
have even that that little bit they have
shall be taken away
that doesn't seem right
but there's a question
he that hath what
vision
people without vision
perish
ambition
drive
a willingness to work
stubbornness
perseverance
faith that roars so loudly
it doesn't give you an opportunity to
hear the doubts that you have within
yourself
you have those qualities
you will get you have those qualities
you restore everything you lost and more
you have those qualities
angels will make room for you come come
come come
let's intervene here because he won't
quit she won't stop we've done
everything and they won't stop come we
gotta intervene now
and then let's go find a wimp somebody
who's stopped
somebody who's allowing themselves to be
consumed
by
fear
they're s weak
yeah because god has not given them a
spirit of fear but of power they ain't
got no power
they're consumed in fear and they can't
even think straight god has not given us
a spirit of fear but a power of a sound
mind habit number five make your
contribution with oprah winfrey this
week i want to talk about this idea of
coming into your own you know we often
hear the phrase
it's thrown around you know so-and-so is
doing so well at her new job she's
really come into her own
it's often used as a compliment a way to
express that someone has been successful
but to me
that definition of success is all about
alignment it's what gary zukov calls
when the personality comes
to serve the energy of the soul where
you are in alignment with what you
really came to do on earth and using
your personality to serve that that's
when you come alive
and that can look different for every
single person because coming into your
own that alignment is different from his
own or her own or my own
but the common denominator is that it's
all about alignment and i learned at a
very young age that if things are to
move forward in
my life i was the one who had to take
responsibility for what mary oliver
calls our one
wild and precious life and not be
defined by other people's idea of who i
should be even if the other people
were my family then i also hope you
remember that there is no timeline for
coming into your own for some people it
happens in their early 20s and for
others they're like 45 50 still trying
to figure it out
and it's never too late because
everybody's journey is different and
this is what i do know
that you don't become what you want you
become what you believe
so
listen to your inner self be kind
and
know for sure that you are here on this
earth because you have a contribution to
make
and
the real work is getting about the
business of making that contribution
hybrid number six pursue your idea with
miles monroe when i was in university
doing my master's degree
in
a business leadership
administration course
[Music]
one of the professors
was teaching a class on economics
and when i walked into the class
for the first time
the professor came in
and he had on
some slippers
a short
pair of blue jean pants
i was cut
by hand
he had on a
t-shirt
and he drove an old volkswagen
and he said to me
unto the class
he said today
we are going to
learn
how to become a millionaire
[Music]
i looked at him in his slippers
his pants
the car he was driving was
old
and i asked him are you a millionaire
he said no so i dropped the class
i never went back
here was a man who was going to teach me
how to be a successful businessman
to become a millionaire
and it wasn't working for him
most of the successful people in the
world
did not learn
business in a classroom
the success of
this ministry
was not taught in a classroom
i doubt that
anything
about this ministry was learned in a
class
you have heard
many times
bishop ayedeepu have said that he
began this ministry with questions
struggle
wanting to know answers
so he began to read books
he began to
study books and
began to
think about information
it was a personal thing
whether it is bill gates
oprah winfrey
or michael jordan
of all the people that you may identify
with
as being
successful people
you may be surprised that nothing that
they do
was ever learned in a seminar
i just completed writing a brand new
book
that will be out in
stores around the world
in about four weeks
january
the book is called
the spirit of leadership
and the book deals with
the missing link
between a follower
and a leader
it took me 30 years of research
and study
to discover what that missing link was
and i discovered that the missing link
that separates a follower from a leader
or a successful business person
from a failing business
is what i call attitude
attitude is a result
of a belief system
that comes from
convictions about yourself
and about your abilities
and leadership is born
when a person discovers
the truth about themselves
and they believe that truth
and commit themselves
to becoming that truth
therefore
learning
the principles of
management learning the techniques
of writing a business plan
learning
organizational skills
will not make you successful in
leadership nor in business
because business
is a result
of the discovery
of a passion
that was deposit in you
from your birth
or should i say before your birth
and you were born to manifest it
business is not about selling things
business
is about selling yourself to the world
true businessmen and women in history
those who have become successful
who we admire
they became successful not because of
techniques
not because
of courses
in college but they became successful
because
they discovered an idea
that became a passion
that created a commitment
that produced
a vision
and they pursued that vision
at all cost and habit number seven the
last one before some very special bonus
clips
is have multiple sources of income with
bob proctor there are only three
strategies for earning money
just three strategies pay close
attention it's m1
m2
and m3
now
before i start into them here's
something you want to burn into your
mind if you don't teach your children
how to earn money odds are pretty good
they're not going to learn school does
not teach us how to earn money you can
go all the way through school you can go
to harvard oxford stanford won't matter
they do not teach you how to earn it
they'll teach you how to
invest it they'll teach you how to store
it they'll teach how to count it but
they do not teach you how to earn it
now there's three strategies if you're
going to teach your children you teach
them number three
but let's start with number one number
one strategy is used by 96 percent of
the population and it won't work it
never has worked
this is where you trade your time for
money you see this this strategy has an
inherent problem it's called saturation
it's
you run out of time i don't care how
effective you are i don't care how much
you're in an hour
you're gonna run out of time you're
trading your time for money it doesn't
work it does not work
number two is an excellent strategy but
it's only used by three percent of the
population
number two is where you invest money to
earn money
now people in the number one strategy
they hear about this and so they
squirrel a little bit of what they're
earning away and they invest it but they
don't understand how to invest it and
they usually lose it if you're going to
invest money you really got to know what
you're doing or go to somebody that has
proved that they know what they're doing
number three is where you invest money
to earn money
now the first two strategies are not the
one you want to focus on here's the one
you want to focus on number three
it's only used by approximately one
person out of a hundred
this is where
this group earns almost all the money
ninety-six percent of all the money
that's earned goes to a very small
select group of people and i'm going to
tell you something i used to think they
were really smart some of them aren't
very smart
i was earning over a million dollars a
year
and i started to analyze what the heck
was i doing how was i doing it i had
stumbled on m3 i didn't know what i was
doing but i was doing it
i had been raised to believe you're
going to earn a lot of money you got to
be really smart i knew i wasn't that
smart but i was earning a fair amount of
money
m3 is used by one percent of the
population but they are 96 of all the
money these people multiply their time
by setting up multiple sources of income
now that's the strategy
how do you set up multiple sources of
income
well some people get that mixed up with
multiple jobs
that's not multiple jobs it's multiple
sources of income the truth is
you can set up sources of income where
you're earning money while you're
sleeping
and it's never been easier than it is
today with the internet and with the way
we're working man you can make it happen
so here we are back again what we want
to do is show you
how to turn your annual income into a
monthly income now pay attention because
this is super important it's very very
important
this can be accomplished by having
multiple sources of income
you check back in history you're going
to find
all wealthy people have always had
multiple sources of income
they didn't have one they had all kinds
of different sources of income
i'm not quite sure how many i've got i
don't even look after them i have
somebody else look after them
sandy's got a team of people my business
partner that looks after our sources of
income
now keep standing here
listen to what we're saying
our world is changing
make no mistake about it
do you know alvin toffler wrote a book a
way back around 1970 called future shock
and he talked about the changes that
were coming
well i was working with earl nightingale
lloyd conant in 1970 and that was a very
popular book around the ninth gal conan
corporation we were all studying and we
were laughing at some of the predictions
we'll say this could never possibly
happen
well move ahead to 40 or 50 years
toffler fell short
he didn't predict it big enough now he
just passed away here a while ago but he
said something before he died that maybe
you should remember
he said the illiterate of the 21st
century will not be the people who
cannot read and write they're going to
be the people who cannot learn
unlearn and relearn most of what we've
learned up to this point
we're going to have to unlearn and then
we're going to learn some new rules
now i am unlearning and learning all the
time and i'll tell you something i've
learned our world is changing yet it's
not getting bigger the world is getting
smaller it is shrinking and here's
something else
this is very important you can have
business all over the world
through
multiple sources of income
here's the question you want to ask
how much do you want
how much do you want
because you can set up sources of income
all over the place
put your heart in your business and your
head in your wallet your heart and your
business the business that you do what
you're running has to feed you has to
feel purposeful has to feel like you
matter you mean something it's having an
impact you're touching lives you're
changing the world right like you need
that passion to drive your business
forward otherwise you're going to quit
but your head
in your wallet
so that you have money coming in so that
you have backup plans so that you can
survive and still feed yourself and your
family and pay the internet
and everything else your head is in your
wallet and your heart is in your
business i think a lot of times
people start
and they're already trying to diversify
you're already trying to
take on opportunities that you just see
as a hot market opportunity for this
year you're trying to take on a million
things because you think one of those
are bound to pay off
if you don't have your heart in the
thing that you're doing you're never
going to win
it's the number one rule of success you
have to love the thing that you're doing
from every entrepreneur that i followed
and looked up to and researched and
profiled and created videos on the
number one rule for success is you have
to love the process of the thing that
you're doing but you have to bring your
head with you
you know you have to bring your head
with you to make smart decisions to to
actually have money left over making
money is really important
whether you're an entrepreneur or not
making money becomes really important
it's not number one but it's got to be
in your top five i'm right now going
through
a process of figuring out what to do
with
my financial situation we've grown
you know we're at 37 people we're
we're building and it's great
and
historically i've just done
my one company
but now i'm in the process of creating a
holding company creating an investment
company
and talking to
different people around
life insurance investments real estate
and
what i keep telling them is my my heart
is in my business
and my head is in my wallet
just to help me make the right strategic
decision
with with money going out
[Music]
i i'm i don't care as long as it's the
the best decision like show me how i'm
going to make money
and not pay taxes right or just pay my
fair share of taxes pay what i'm
required to pay right i am
ultra safe
uh i do not want calls from the
government i want backup plans upon
backup plans for
for my money and where i'm investing it
but then my heart is in my business
and i'm gonna keep coming up with new
innovative
crazy ideas of things that i can do
inside my company
at the beginning the very beginning i
had no money
it was all it was all heart all just
trying to get something off the ground
and i think people often will
prematurely
uh diversify
we'll prematurely find
18 different sources of income where the
smart thing to do at the beginning is
probably just pick one
like pick the one that will actually pay
you the fastest
that's still inside of your your mission
right that's still inside of the vision
you want to create for yourself pick the
one that will pay you the fastest that
then allows other things to happen
when i'm talking to an entrepreneur and
i asked him you know what what's the
vision that you got for yourself where
do you want to go what are you trying to
create what's the what's the positive
ripple you want to have on the world
right what is that
they tell me their big plan and big
goals and big dreams look amazing
okay well what are you going to do
tomorrow like how do we start funding
this because they're still at a job
or the or they just started and they're
just making ends meet and i
i remember being that person remember
being that person and being too ashamed
and embarrassed to ask for help and
making 300 bucks a month like that was
me i get it
okay so what are you gonna do to start
building that and that's where people
struggle that's where people fall down
it's like what are the next steps
you can see the end picture and the goal
and the vision that you've got for
yourself and what you want to make but
from where you are now to where you're
going to be it just feels too
too big too slow too impossible needing
venture capital funding needing a whole
ton of support no you just need to
figure out what's the next step that
will start to pay you for what you're
doing this is where people often don't
want to have the conversation because
they just want to do everything for free
that's great but you have to you have to
make money doing this
so that you can make this your full-time
thing so you can
hire a team so you can expand you can
have a bigger reach you can have a much
bigger impact you can actually create
the world that you want to create again
money is not number one but you have to
figure out a way to make money so inside
of your big dream
what is the next step that you have to
take
that's gonna start to get you paid
and often it's coaching often it's
selling your time right
often it's taking the expertise that you
have inside you you solve the problem
for yourself now you're going to help
other people do it you're paid to do it
how do you get to where you're at how do
you think the way you think how can you
self-actualize how can you be positive
do you have
can you identify a reason well for me
it's a little easier than maybe for some
people because one when you're down and
out more than once you don't know money
no nothing and something good happens oh
boy this is great but i was with all due
respect i was born i think positive i
my mom would always tell me my god be
careful mom i'm gonna be just fine i was
kind of think boring positive
you know then obviously when you're down
you go up you get even more positive
because you're so happy and then when
you have an abundance of something and
you get to share it with people and you
see a good end result it just it's happy
if you ever you do something for
somebody else and ask absolutely nothing
in return it's the greatest high you'll
ever get now i went through the 60s okay
it's the greatest high you'll ever get
when you help somebody say that and you
ask nothing in return yes absolutely
nothing in return it's higher than
smoking anything is that what you how
you would describe a good giver
yeah when you give to somebody or
something or some environment whether
it's the environment for the planet or
for people
and you ask nothing in return you do it
because it's the thing to do
oh you get a good high everyone likes
being knowledge but do it sometime and
don't tell anybody you did it like
there'll be times austin especially i'll
go downtown and when i'm in l.a i'll do
it because i was homeless here once and
i'll hand out hundred dollar bills i'll
just go back to this for you
and i just keep on walking and one lady
i gave a stack to it was a ten thousand
dollar stack she was just the kind of
sweetest lady and i talked to her a
little bit she told me a little about
her life and i said can i give you a
couple dogs oh no no i found out a way
to make it okay because i don't like to
ask for anything they said okay so i
just held her hand and i said can i put
a note in your pocket sure so i just put
a note in the pocket i realized just
built ten thousand output in her pocket
there was folded with a rubber band i
said you are so blessed
once you wait a few minutes before
reading my note say a little prayer then
read that out okay and i disappeared you
know now i'm going through and teaching
myself neural networks and you know
doing the same thing with machine
learning and gans and this and that
because
ai
is going to have more of an impact than
the internet did ai plus new types of
chipsets plus 5g is going to change
things far more than we've ever seen
anything change and understanding where
and how to apply it is going to be
critical but just as important knowing
how to sep
segregate and separate the
yeah right is as important because every
email you are about to send me
is going to say i have this ai solution
and we're using algorithms
yeah of course you are right and then
what what really makes you different
what really sets you apart but if i
didn't do that work if i didn't sit down
and do the aws machine learning
tutorials if i didn't go on youtube and
take you know the nyu introduction to
neural networks or whatever i'm not
going to know it i'm not going to be
able to apply it and i'm not going to be
able to be first and that's fun that's
fun knowing i get to kick the ass to
some 22 year old nyu graduate that's
awesome you know
you know i find if i'm stressed about
something it's usually because i'm not
doing anything about it and so if i'm
stressed about something i'm trying to
figure out why am i stressed i'm
listening to my body
as a signal
that i'm that something is awry and then
i find that the stress goes away
the second i take the first step of you
know identify the source of the stress
why am i stressed about this what's
going on and then
you know talk to somebody about it find
you know find allies
um you know i would say that uh
if you can find
friends
who are interested in similar things or
want to help you solve a problem
problem solving is
is inspiring for me all by itself i have
as long as i have allies there's nothing
more fun than getting in a room
with a group of
inventors and saying look
here's the problem let's invent a
solution to it and as soon as you start
doing that i find that it turns from
something that might create stress
into something that creates fun what's
the best advice that you've received
someone told me that what you delegate
is 80
as good as you would have done it
yourself let it go oh wow i took
inventory of what am i good at what am i
not good at what do i you know enjoy and
don't enjoy and they're usually the same
thing ironically like i was very clear
in the first year i was not good at
shipping and handling and i wasn't good
at you know
so many different things about managing
the inventory but i loved inventing the
next idea i loved the brand i loved the
way that i was communicating with
consumers so being able to free yourself
up to do what you do best
and let the people who do the other
aspects
do it i write down my day and what i do
is i go back and study that day like
sometimes i might i might get sick i
might be over trained i might
um
gain a couple pounds here i might feel
whatever
that and i it's like my accountability
journal
of what i'm doing with my life physical
mental
i had an eating journal all that
and helps me go back to once again study
i'm a lab rat
and i study myself
and i'm like when i'm feeling [ __ ] up
i go okay what i do last week
and usually i can find out where i
messed up
last week you know how much i'm
traveling how much i'm sleeping how much
i'm doing all this stuff and and through
journaling man you can really figure out
so much
about where you're messing up in life
and what you need to fix about yourself
taking constant inventory constantly
honest about that and that's thing about
you cannot put in there yeah it's gotta
be a real a real journal about hey today
i messed up here today i should have
been a better person here and not just
saying it but actually trying to fix it
tomorrow do it anyway
is a mindset trick that you can use when
you start to feel excuses rolling up it
works a lot like the five-second rule
so you
have said to yourself okay i'm gonna
talk to my boss today
about that thing that i've been avoiding
talking to them about
or maybe you've said something like i'm
gonna go to the gym today or tomorrow or
whatever and then the moment comes where
you've got to have that conversation
or the moment comes where it's time to
pack up your bag and leave your desk and
go to the gym
and what always happens
you don't feel like it
i bet there are plenty of you watching
that have made a commitment that i'm not
going to have a drink tonight and then
guess what happens when you get home
you don't feel like not drinking you
feel like having a drink and so here's
what do it anyway has done for me
the idea that i just do it anyway
has pushed me to realize and to
recognize that there are a lot of
moments where there are things in my
life that i really want to do
i need to do
i should do
but when the moment comes
i don't feel like it
and so i pull out this idea of you know
what i'm just going gonna do it anyway
it's raining outside i said i would go
for a short run i don't feel like it i'm
gonna do it anyway it's six o'clock in
the morning i'm tired
it's cold
i laid out my yoga clothes but now i
don't feel like it what do i do i do it
anyway when you start to say to yourself
i'm gonna do it anyway what happens is
something really cool you acknowledge
that there are feelings that you have
that are trying to swoop in and hijack
you
you acknowledge them and you basically
say guess what
i'm gonna do it anyway you know if if
you
see self-improvements not even just with
cars with your own body you know when
you go work out
do you feel better when you come out of
a gym all pumped up or you feel better
when you haven't worked out for a month
yeah of course you know you're when you
go to the gym you know you're building
your you know something happens when you
see changes in your body with your
assets when you see even
gaining a good friend i have my down
days you know i'm sure you do too we're
all human you know you could have all
the money in the world you're still
going to have a bad day you know
absolutely you don't know what's going
to cause it but you know you do and you
know for me working out is great i have
a personal trainer three times a week
and then when i don't have my personal
trainer i just get out of bed and drop
on the floor and do 20 push-ups 30
push-ups i do it until i can't do it
anymore and then i hit the shower and i
feel great you know and it's you know
it's just
keeping
the fluids going you know your mind
fresh yeah because workout not just
improves your physics it also helps your
mind agreed and
sometimes it helps your mentality more
than your physique but people don't
realize it you know it helps you focus
grant rant of the day the one you need
to live with wake up to every day is
that right there
okay beat the sun up folks you got to
beat the sun up if you can't beat up the
roll up of the sun up
you're going to get beat up in life okay
i've been doing this for a long time now
i'd say beat that thing up that monster
out there that warms this planet that
nourishes
and gives us light but you can't live a
10x life if you're not beating the sun
up
so many of you complain about how much
time you have you don't have time man
because you don't beat the sun up get
started early and when you get started
early that means you need to shut it
down early okay shut it down early so
you get sleep i was i was asleep last
night at nine o'clock so i could beat
the sun up tomorrow this morning and see
the world wake up with me
in order to be successful i believe that
like many many habits you develop
but i think the one habit that you must
develop
that will change your life that will
change your world is this one thing i
want you to imagine this i want you to
kind of draw a circle if you're watching
my video you are in front of your desk
go ahead and do that i want to draw a
big circle and within the circle i want
to draw everything that you have in your
life right now
that you already have
maybe it's the the car that you drive
the income that you have
the the house that you live in
the the vacation that you already take
the people around you right
doesn't have to be materialistic but
doesn't really matter what it is the
things that you already have right now
you process in your life
i want to draw that within the circle
write all those things down then i want
you to
outside the circle write down everything
that you want in your life but you don't
have
okay so maybe now you are driving a
a
hyundai
and you actually want a mercedes okay
let's draw them so right down the
mercedes outside the circle
maybe you're living in a condo but you
actually want to live in a big house
okay write that outside of the circle so
i want you to write that
so within a circle is everything that
you have right now outside the circle is
everything that you want but don't have
so i want you to look at this right now
what is the circle
the circle is your comfort zone
everything you have right now in your
life they're all within your comfort
zone
and your comfort zone is your income
zone i want you to look at everything
that you want but don't have where are
they
they're outside of your comfort zone
depends on where you put it
so in order to get what you want but
don't have in life what do you have to
do you need to stretch and expand your
comfort zone because if it's within your
comfort zone guess what you already have
them
so everything that you want in life that
you don't have right now is all outside
of your comfort zone
so i believe the number one habit you
need to develop to be successful
is on a consistent if not a daily basis
do things that make you feel
uncomfortable
it is that simple because you look at
what holds most people back what holds
you back
is fear
fear of the unknown fear of failure
fear of rejection
fear of success
all these things is all outside your
comfort zone human being because we're
creature of habits we tend to operate
day to day and do the same thing again
and again and again but if you have a
habit you make a habit that you do
things on a consistent basis that you
don't usually do it makes you scared it
scares
out of you it makes you stretch your
comfort zone that's how you gradually
expand that and get more of what you
want maybe it's going to the event that
you've never been to
maybe it's meeting that successful
people that in that intimidates you
maybe it's reading a book that you have
no interest reading in maybe it's
driving a different path that you
usually go home this way hey you know
what i'm gonna drive a different path
and see something a little bit different
right maybe it's watching a video that
you don't usually watch
maybe you're interested in certain
topics maybe you're watching a youtube
video just on prank but suddenly you
watch something that is uninspirational
and motivational that's practical
there's business
related and that changes the way they
think about stuff it started with that
one thing that one video and if you do
that
not one time not two times not three
times but
hundreds and hundreds of times on a
consistent basis i believe that is the
habit not just to be successful but to
stay successful i have to show up at
work with the right attitude and with
the positive energy
and
i actually
had a t-shirt made that said positive
energy is a part of your job description
right so the the idea that um i want to
show up with the right energy i want to
show up you know we're all here you know
even now we're all here we're trying to
feed our families we're we're trying to
have a good time we're trying you know
this is an important
uh part of our lives our time is all
that we have so to me it's hugely
important to deliver positive energy
in a way because it's vibrant so
if
i come with positive energy then someone
else is going to pick up on the positive
energy and you're going to take it home
to your families and you know so for me
it's just hugely important to approach
everything and everybody at every turn
with the the most positive loving
kindness that i can generate for the
audition when you first met de niro
that was yeah i mean that was one of
those incredible auditions that came
around that i i suppose every kid had
been waiting for for a long period of
time because
it's just not that often that you get a
starring role above robert de niro in
this incredible you know
screen playing with you know ellen
barkin and michael caton jones it was
just
everyone was sort of fiending for this
role and um
i i got down i suppose to the final five
and it was like a last sort of day
toby was there and i
i do remember
thinking to myself uh i got to do
something i got to do something to stand
out
and um
in the audition it was art lindsen
michael kate and jones artleton who was
the producer and de niro
and i remember uh it was a mustard jar
scene
and he had to jam a mustard jar in my
eye
repeatedly it was an abuse scene
and
the script sort of didn't call for it
but i got up and i he said now is it
empty is it empty and i got up and i
screamed
like completely unnecessary but i
screamed in his face
and i sat there you know
with my head uh you know looking like a
red tomato and and and everyone
started laughing at me in the entire
room de niro everybody was in hysterics
and i sat there frozen thinking oh my
god i just screwed this entire
opportunity up
and i just sat there frozen and then you
know bob and traditional de niro fashion
kind of just looked at me went
it's good
and then you know we carried on during
the scene and i think i actually had
dinner with denir recently and he told
me no i was the one who said i was the
one who said you should get to get the
job where did you get that that business
sense because you you surpassed
everybody in in boxing and sports and
everything in general i'm watching you
as like you bigger than the nfl
franchise uh just uh
my team me believing you know i'm gonna
be honest
me and a lot of my guys and a lot of my
i'm saying i have a team also but you
know my team don't get in there
and go to war like i go to war but they
go to war on the outside my team go to
war
i'm on i'm on i'm very very tough on my
team
um
i i i want my team to be
the best that they can be
on the outside and but as far as on the
outside you know al haymon
that's the oj right that's og a legend a
legend
a very true businessman
um leonard l b
matt master degree
you know in business so you know when
you surround yourself with people like
this just
um just being around certain individuals
certain individuals like even been
around don king being around bob aaron
being around just different people
that's been in the game a long time and
and you know um my being there buddies
you know every time i got around my
being there buddies i was more like um
it's cool to come over your house but i
need a house like this yeah it's cool to
write on your yacht but i need a yacht
like this it's cool to write on your jet
but i want a jet like that and i said no
i don't want to ride on yours you showed
me how to get it
you can't be my friend if you can't show
me how to get it because once they show
me how to get it then i can install it
in my children then it goes it goes
down it's a bloodline thing yes so it's
about wealth you know i'm no longer rich
i'm wealthy we've had this tradition for
i don't know probably seven or eight
years at the company uh where every week
uh we have a q a
where um where our employees can come
and ask me any question that they want
about what's going on and
what the what the direction of the
company is or questions or things that
they read about in the press or that
their friends who use the product um
what what they're asking them
and um and it's been this really
important tradition for us
both because we really believe in an
openness and communication and that's
kind of what facebook is all about
but it's also really important for for
me and for
running the company to be able to get
feedback right and and to be able to
learn what's on people's minds um what
are what our employees and folks who who
are who are part of our team are
thinking about
and um and just kind of a lot of the
time there are good questions that
people ask that change the way that we
that we think about what we're building
and what we're here to do in the world
and that often make us go think and
reevaluate how we should be approaching
different problems rich
why do you sleep in a tent for those
that don't know for the last two years
i've been sleeping outside
in this thing a lot of people have been
asking me why do you do that and it
basically boils down to
three fundamental reasons the first is
i just sleep better in a tent outside
the second reason is that it really has
helped me connect with
nature and the outdoors and i think our
primal disposition
and the third reason i've been doing it
is because
fundamentally it's a stoic practice a
couple years ago i started struggling
with
trying to get a deep sleep unless i was
training super duper hard i just found
it difficult to get the restfulness that
my body and my mind need and at the time
our bedroom that i share with my wife
julie was either
too cold
for her or too hot for me then i had an
experience
where
we as a family all slept on our roof one
night we have a flat roof and we did it
just for fun with the kids and i had the
most restful
peaceful night of sleep
in recent memory
being outdoors
breathing that outdoor air sleeping
under the stars is a very simple and
basic way of reconnecting with what it
means to be fundamentally human
we live in this super fast-paced culture
you got to get your hustle on you got to
like work 24 hours a day and if you're
not being productive in every moment of
your waking existence then you're
wasting time and you're falling behind
and with that comes a deep
prioritization of sleep sleep is for
slackers right
and nothing could be further from the
truth
i know that i can't perform at my very
best unless i get eight hours of sleep
and it's not just the amount of time
that i sleep it's the quality of that
sleep it's the caliber of that sleep it
is my opinion that everybody should be
doing everything they can to enhance
that quality of their evening hours and
i found that by sleeping in a tent it's
almost like this
hack towards improving the caliber of my
sleep so that i can show up throughout
my day and excel be totally focused be
totally present have good energy be in a
good mood and all of that derives from
sleep so if you really
take the time to prioritize the quality
and the amount of time that you're
sleeping every night
you will realize quantum gains in your
productivity in your output throughout
your day
find the good
now find the good what does that have to
do with making more money here's why i
know unsuccessful people figure out
what's wrong with the world figure out
why people are holding them back figure
out why the advice they got is bad
figure out why the president is bad or
the economy is bad or where they live is
bad and it's like our subconscious is
designed for that so i want to just
throw that away i want to give you a new
rule like
you've heard this before
but maybe right now is the first time
you ever really heard it and you decide
to implement it in your life if you want
that life you crave so
find the good you see it's really easy
to find what's wrong with the world we
know that it's really easy to find
what's wrong with the people around you
but what if you shifted that framework
and your obsession was to find what's
right to find what's good
to look for the good in people rather
than the bad to look for the good in the
marketing strategies that you're working
on look for the good in your family even
though they're a pain in the ass
sometimes but they're trying to protect
you as simple as this little shift sound
you're like oh dean i thought you were
going to tell me how to make money i am
i am telling you how to make money and
i'm telling you how to be happy and i'm
telling you how to thrive when other
people struggle and when the economy
turns like it's gonna you could be the
one ahead because you're gonna have to
find the good when the whole world is
finding what's wrong so one simple hack
today this week obsess on looking
for the good talk to me about set points
that was something really interesting in
what you talk about around the stories
and things that we carry that i found
really interesting sure so
maxwell maltz wrote a great book many
many years ago in the probably the 70s
called psycho cybernetics right and
maxwell maltz was a surgeon who
performed surgery on people and what he
noticed is even after plastic surgery
that he performed on people some people
didn't see any change in their faces and
it was visible to everybody else but not
to them because they had a map of what
they thought they look like yes so we
all have
a map of reality we have a map of what
we think we look like
and any deviation on the physical level
to that map to that visual
representation we have in our brains
that doesn't match the map your brain
deletes or distorts it
so
when we were working with real estate or
when i worked with business owners in
addition to upgrading knowledge and
skills
if you think about how let's say income
we have set points for how much income
we earn so whether it's ten thousand a
year or twenty or fifty or a hundred or
million it doesn't matter we get this
set point and then we behave the way we
need to behave and we feel what we need
to feel to earn that income
and over a period of time it becomes
part of the brain's default mode network
so we develop set points for everything
and so if the set points in the brain
and there's a psycho-cybernetic
mechanism in the brain a control and
response mechanism in the brain
and it's our brain
why not learn how
to reset the set point
and so now we're looking at what
technologies are available to help help
reset that uh what uh evidence-based
methods are there to set that or to
reset that
and so when we take let's say
visualization right and you start to see
yourself even if the picture's not clear
in your mind of achieving the next level
of your success whether it's releasing
weight and keeping it off getting into a
relationship that you love and are happy
and whether it's to make two or three or
five times more money and live a certain
type of lifestyle that allows you to do
the things that freedom
with having money allows you to do if
you start in your mind first and you
impress
that through conscious efforts into the
subconscious mind
it then causes thoughts and emotions and
behaviors
so i like to work from the outside in
and from the inside out so use both
i want every advantage dude i'm a huge
believer in identity driving
behaviors um i have a hard time
explaining to people though how to adopt
a new identity how do you
how have you done it in your own life i
think that's the best yeah i mean my
identity i mean obviously this is
a work in progress right i would say
that i would start with
the they call it the two smallest world
words in the english language but
they're their two most powerful words in
the english language it's i am
right i am because whatever you put
after that determines your destination
or your your destiny right and i think
your identity is who you believe you are
and i feel like when we're talking about
playing to the edge of our limits and
really playing there and living in that
place where we're stretching you know i
do believe and i get inspired every time
i see your insta story you're like it's
like 4 30 and you're working out you're
doing your work but that's who you are
right you don't have to fight it because
you can't imagine yourself not doing
that and that's the level of that that i
think is what's most important so i
would think about going through an
exercise and i've done this with friends
i've had them sit or in groups we do
these conferences and such and i find i
i have people pair up with someone they
don't know and what they're going to do
is they're going to do an exercise i am
and they're going to talk a bit they're
literally going to fill in the blanks
for three minutes until i call time so
you have to go like and you could do
this right now like if you were to fill
in i am blank like i would say you know
i am a student i am a teacher i am a son
i am you know all this and but
eventually i'll get to a point where i
don't know what else to say and that's
what the real interesting answers come
out of right because it's a great way
for networking and knowing somebody else
but it also shows us this really big
tapestry of our life to the point that
we've gone to right now where we could i
relate to these aspects of ourselves and
i think it's a nice exercise when we
talk about self-awareness being a
superpower really knowing who we think
we are because if we don't believe that
we're our public speaker or we're a
great parent or we're a great learner or
genius then we'll never be able to reach
our full potential because that will
always be the ceiling that we bump up
against you're gonna said that you uh
sit around with your team and so forth
but you don't like meetings before 10
a.m no you like to get eight hours of
sleep and don't like um power points
explain all that why is that okay many
so i i like to putter in the morning i
get up early i go to bed early i get up
early i like to putter in the mornings i
like to read the newspaper i like to
have coffee i like to have
breakfast with my kids before they go to
school so i have my
kind of puttering time is very important
to me and so that's why i set my first
meeting for 10 o'clock
i like to do my high iq meetings
before lunch like anything that's going
to be really mentally challenging that's
a 10 o'clock meeting and because by 5
p.m i'm like
i can't think about that today let's try
this again tomorrow at 10 a.m
and um and so then on sleep i get eight
hours of sleep i prioritize it unless
i'm traveling in different time zones
sometimes it's impossible but i am very
um focused on it and and and for me i
need adults to sleep i think better i
have more energy my mood is better all
these things and think about it as a
senior executive
what do you really get
paid to do as a senior executive
you get paid to make a small number
of high quality decisions
your your job is not to make thousands
of decisions every day so let's say that
i
slept six hours a day or let's go really
crazy and say i slept four hours a day
so now i just got four
so-called productive hours back
so if i was going to
you know have say 12 hours of productive
time during any waking day now all of a
sudden i have 12 plus 4 i have 16
productive hours
so i have 33
percent more
time to make decisions so if i was going
to make
you know 100 decisions now i can make
133 decisions if i did that arithmetic
wrong
i'm sorry
and um
and so
you make 133 decisions
is that really worth it if the quality
of those decisions might be lower
because you're tired or grouchy or any
number of things
now it's different if it's a startup
company i mean you know you're really
you know when amazon was 100 people
that's a different story but but
amazon's not a startup company and all
of our senior executives operate the
same way i do they work in the future
they live in the future none of the
people who report to me should really be
focused on the current quarter
i always tell people sometimes i get you
know we'll have a good
quarterly conference call or something
and and wall street will like our
quarterly results and i'll get
people will stop me and say
congratulations on your quarter and i
say thank you but what i'm really
thinking is
that quarter was baked three years ago i
right now i'm working on a quarter
that's going to reveal itself in 2021
sometime
and that's what you need to be doing you
need to be out sort of you know two or
three years in advance
and um if you are and then why do i need
to make 100 decisions today if i make
like three good decisions a day that's
enough i certainly was uh quite um
i was very very bookish i was reading
all the time so i was either reading
uh working on my computer
reading comics playing dungeon dragons
that kind of thing
um i understand hitchhiker's guide to
the galaxy that wonderful boot by
douglas adams that was a that was a key
book for you
what was it about that book that that
fired your imagination um yeah so
uh i guess when i was
in uh around 12 or 13 i had company
existential crisis and i was reading
various books
um
on trying to figure out the meaning of
life and well like what does it all mean
because
uh it
it starts seeming quite meaningless and
then
um
uh my we happen to have like some some
books by nietzsche and schopenhauer in
the house which you should not read at
age 14
is bad
it's really negative um
so so uh but but then i then i read the
hitchhiker's guide the galaxy was like
quite positive i think and
um
and it sort of highlighted the the
an important point which is that a lot
of times the question is harder than the
answer and if you can properly phrase
the question then the answer is the easy
part
and so
uh
the if to agree that we can
better
understand the universe then we better
know what questions to ask and
um then whatever the question is that
most approx approximates what's the
meaning of life
you know that that's that's the question
we could ultimately get closer to
understanding
and so i thought well to agree that we
can
expand the scope and scale of
consciousness and
knowledge
human knowledge then that would be a
good thing you went to harvard and you
dropped out have you ever thought how
your life could be better off if you had
gotten your harvard degree
well i i'm a weird dropout because i
take college courses all the time i love
learning company courses and and things
so i loved being a student and there
were smart people around and you know
they fed you and they gave you these
nice grades that made you feel smart uh
so i i feel it was unfortunate
uh that i didn't get to stay there but i
don't think i missed any knowledge
because you know whatever i needed to
learn i would i was still in a
learning mode
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want seven more rich people habits for
you to try check the video right there
next to me i think you'll love it
continue to believe i'll see you there
you absolutely must if you want to be
legendary in your marketplace you
absolutely have to do this schedule 60
minutes a day
for your learning it could be listening
to audiobooks